[Musique]
merci beaucou c'est une chanson qui a
éta écrite par Robert desn Robert des
c'est Yanis panos et c'est l'histoire
d'une toute jeune personne qui est
rêveuse et fragile voilà
voilà
en effeuillant la fleur des champs la
blanche et tendre Marguerite je rêve
d'un pompier pas méchant ou d'un soldat
dans sa guérite nous irions dans un beau
jardin comme un prince avec sa princesse
de minuit jusqu'au matin nous serions
tout miel et caresses voilà rêve et
fragile ou la
brutalité me tourne la bile et me fait
pleurer
j'aime les mots tendres et les songes
bleus mon cœur peut se fendre pour un
[Musique]
amoureux je suis pareil aux velis et je
suis pareil au grand lis et pareil à la
fraise mure je suis une faible nature
l'amour tourne mon estomac et quand je
rêve aux aventures ma chère frémis j'en
suis gaga pour prendre ma
température rêveuse fragile ou la
brutalité me tourne la bille et me fait
pleurer j'aime les motendre et les
songes bleus mon cœur peut se fendre
pour un
amoureux
hélas je viens d'avoir 100 ans et je
veux quelqu'un de vivant car le rêvis
bien triste et fade je voudrais le
marquis de sad ou bien
un gros garçon bouché qu'il me Drane me
fasse loucher ou qu'il me mette en
marmelade mais que je ne sois plus en
rade rêveuse et fragile la qualité me
tournez la B et me faire rêver j'aime
les Mons tendr et les songes bleus mon
cœur peut se fendre pour un
amoureux ah la
[Musique]
brutalité